Good morning everyone.
Welcome to a joint select
committee hearing a plastic
pollution and its effect on the
California coast my name is mark
stone on the chair of select
committee on coastal protection
and access.
To California's natural
resources I am joined today by
other something members.
Assembly member Kevin McCarty
who.
Select committee on it what.
I was waste reduction is waste
reduction.
This not committee on coastal
protection we've done a number
of things around threats to the
cause of our men including
classic ocean pollution things
and so.
As we can't really talk about
plastic and pollution without.
The waste management waste
reduction issue and that's why
Mister McCarty I decided it
would be a good idea to do a
joint hearing on that.
We also have seventy members off
Kalra and were Friedman who are
joining us here today.
So often times when we go out to
the district with select
committees are not.
Always well attended by a
legislator have some significant
legislators and will give
everyone a chance. To speak a
little bit of logistics there
some parking information on the
table by the doors if you have
not registered your vehicle
using that parking information.
You might end up with that
ticket.
So feel free to grab one of
those and make sure that you are.
Officially logged into the
system so that you don't get a
ticket restrooms are out to the
left you'll notice we close the
blinds behind this to the bill
try to pay some attention to us
and not to the incredible scene
had is actually out though.
Out the windows and out the door
but feel free. To get up and
move around.
As necessary.
So I just wanted to make sure
that we frame this as talking
about pollution in the marine
environment and how we are
responsible for waste reduction
and from my standpoint.
Waste reduction is really not
only about the back and cleaning
up what's there but trying to be
responsible how we understand
products product manufacturing.
The whole retail chain so that
every product especially with
plastic plastic packaging war
parts that are single use or
short duration use.
We have a way of collecting and
managing that responsibly.
If we doubt what we see often is
that that ends up.
In the creeks rivers and
watersheds and ultimately out
into the ocean and even though
ram the Monterey Bay very proud
that we have so many people
willing to go out and do coastal
cleanup days.
Add we have been working with
state parks.
Because we have a lot of beach
side state parks and the county
cities to put their resources
available to clean up the beach
is it should not is an issue
that should not always fall on
the volunteers for the local
jurisdictions to be responsible
to clean up.
Think we need a broader.
Policies and and more
comprehensive solutions where
everyone is engaged in taking
some responsibility for helping
address the plastic waste
problem.
And so this is where we're going
to explore a number of issues
around the coastline look at
some next steps and then take
some public comment.
So many turn the microphone over
to coach chair this Mister
McCarty and then ask the other
so members to weigh in before we
get to the past.
Good morning thank you for all
coming out.
Today and then thank you --
Someone member stone for walk
beautiful district and I don't
think you could have picked a
better location.
No you don't trust has which is
why you close the blinds behind
this -- And
you know you got you represent
the coast here but it's
important that we all on the
coast. Forty million
Californians whether or not you.
Live in a coastal community as
well.
And that we want to make sure we
preserve the coast for future
generations but also in
districts like mine we have.
Rivers and streams and creeks
and other plastic issues impact
those areas and of course the
end up and in the day in the
ocean as well so --
I serve on the natural resources
committee --
With you and I and I also chair
of the select committee on waste
reduction and recycling so --
Plastics and its impact the
environment and recycling waste
reduction all kind of go hand in
hand.
And this hearing today is an
important opportunity. For us
understand --
The the dynamics of the issue
see here in California as well
as a potential remedies that --
That would be key looking at ten
twenty nineteen and beyond and I
certainly look forward.
To our panelists and our public
discussion here today and to get
a look for to today's here thank
you.
Thank you misread.
Thank you I want to first thank
the chairs --
Chair McCarty ensure stone for
holding this hearing and
inviting.
Your colleagues and the public
to join us I represent for
cities in Los Angeles Los
Angeles county including part of
the city of Los Angeles.
So will my district does not
touch the coastline certainly my
city does.
Anna's chair McCarty said we all
have ownership of the coastlines
in California.
The justice last week I was
horrified to see a story in the
LA times about how we are
literally eating salt by eating
plastic.
Because of the amount of micro
of micro pollution that's
entered the food stream through
salt and other products.
So this is something that's on
the mind of of myself and
certainly of my constituents.
Think we're starting to
understand the scope of the
problem in terms of the public
understanding.
But all of us are struggling to
find solutions.
With some concrete actions that
we can take over the next
legislative session next couple
of years to start really
tackling this problem.
Thank you score.
Thank you.
Chair stone Chen McCarty and and
my colleague summer Friedman --
Oskol representing some it is a
twenty seven over the hill in
San Jose.
And my echo the comments of my
colleagues here and this would
add that --
As high as often times in the
case special last --
Of input in in recent years --
Ill California's not only that
in terms of trying to see what
we can do to prevent Harmon --
In our own jurisdiction but
really it.
I think we have a responsibility
to wrestle world should ever
weekend in partnering up with so
many others around the world are
trying to deal.
With the issue of our oceans
event plastics --
Of from continuing. To invade
our oceans --
Sea level rise and on and on and
on these are issues that affect
California and and all
California's matter where they
live.
But it's also a global issue and
I think it's one more area where
we need to lead --
And as global leaders and and
I'm grateful to be able to serve.
A with leaders like those that
are at the table here with me
and and certainly --
I'm interested in learning from
the folks committee speaking
today -- And
and I really appreciate these
kinds hearings because it gives
us opportunity when we're in our
off season or not in the
legislative cycle to repair what
comes next what we need to do.
To continue to to lead on our
state for its of thank you.
Thank you ending it is
significant to have some Inland
legislators here and and I know
we have all worked.
Very closely on some significant
environmental policy.
But it is true the Californians
feel an owner it is a good
resource it's part of
Californians identity.
And as a formal.
Former California coastal
commissioner when things we did
find across the coast or across
the state.
Was people valued the regulatory
scheme to protect access protect
the beauty protect the ability
for people to feel that
ownership and be able to go to
the coast and so.
As we talk about coastal issues.
We really are expanding beyond
what just.
The coastal jurisdictions thank
but it's very very much.
Eighty issue for the entire
[inaudible]
Population California.
Right so our first panel will be
discussing effective on the
coast line.
And we have UCSC professor mark
car and I want to thank you CSE
for hosting us today this is an
incredible facility and and a
great resource.
We also have Amy will from from
the Monterey Bay aquarium and
hollywire from the ocean
protection council and I will
note that the ocean protection
council be be.
Here tomorrow so dates a couple
days of oceans issue.
Alright so professor Kerr thank
you -- Let
me start.
Chair stone by thinking the
chairs as well as the committees
for the opportunity to to engage
in this discussion.
Today.
When it came to identifying with
the panelists we're going to do --
I again picked the short straw I
am the one who is going to
describe the significance of the
problem.
And then all the people who
follow me are going to describe
how they're contributing to the
solution --
So I want to start my frame.
And really the core of the
problem is the ever growing
amount of plastic that is
produced in the world.
By demand of consumers and so
this graph shows the amount in
million tons of plastic that is
being generated globally over
time and I want to point out in
this figure.
That by the year two thousand we
were producing about two hundred
million times.
By twenty ten ten years later we
are up to three hundred million.
In only five years later we're
up at four hundred million tons
per year --
So it's not just that there's so
much it's the fact that we're
producing in more and more at an
ever growing rate.
And so of course with all that
production.
It we end up with debris
material that that gets
discarded in various ways and I
want to point out in this figure
that.
Those the major producers and
they're and also the major
sources of debris include Asian
comp countries like China and us
the United States of America.
Next slide please.
And so with all that waste the
to being generated --
By these countries.
Of the fader that material --
Varies between recycling and
other --
Consequences.
This graph shows that over time
the proportion that's actually
being recycled.
Is growing right and so by
twenty fifteen roughly 20% of
the waste that's being generated.
Is actually being recycled --
Another 25% or more gets
incinerated.
But which is probably spooky in
its own right.
But notice that roughly 60% of
the the plastic that's being
produced is getting discarded
either in the landfills or other
fates -- And
I'm one of those fades is the
leader in coastal areas and so
this graph shows again those
countries.
That have the largest country of
coastal letter of plastic debris
in the world.
And noticed that the United
States is generating on the
order of two hundred and seventy
five thousand tons per year of
discarded plastic.
Waste on and this is.
Constrained to fifty kilometers
along the coast line so much at
that production is being --
Is being a weight that --
To to discarded on the coast
line -- And
so the question is how does all
this plastic get into the ocean
the vast vast majority of it
comes from the land.
Roughly aid is 7280% of ocean
plastic debris.
Comes from the land.
The other --
2230% comes from ocean sources
about half of that importantly
comes from debris associated
with fishing fishing lines
fishing that this is a big
source of plastic debris.
And then other --
Ocean based sources as vessels.
But importantly.
It's the vast majority of it
comes from land and to important
conduits by which plastic debris
gets to the ocean.
Is either through major river
systems as illustrated here with
this graph this photo of the Los
Angeles river --
That transports much of that
cools the letter to the coast
line -- The
other this the smaller micro
plastics are also did cards
through waste water systems that
that -- That
are not treated --
Because of the size of the
material next.
So what are the consequences of
all of these plastics that are --
Moved and transported into the
ocean so there's five major sort
of categories of ecological
consequences. One particularly
important consequences
entanglement --
And this tends to occur
especially for large marine
mammals --
And see birds as illustrated in
these photos --
Much of that entanglement is is
material that's lots from
fishing.
Again naps and lines next slide --
But another major --
Consequence is that direct
ingestion of plastics by a wide
variety of species.
And then one of the the two big
problems with all that ingestion.
Is that it can a clue the
digestive track so that animals
can no longer properly digest
material passage through their
bodies.
And as a consequence they die
out right.
The other is that the material
may collect in their gods.
And it takes up space that would
otherwise be filled with
nutrient rich food material.
And as a consequence it greatly
reduces the growth rate of
organisms which again alternate
reduces their reproductive
potential and increases their
likelihood of of Diane
[inaudible]
Next slide --
Then there is the the problem of
contamination that was mentioned
earlier.
In this is where the plastic
materials --
Actually our talks and toxicants --
And contaminants for organisms
and I start with that image
there which is --
Shows a a survey of the country
PC bees --
Impeached plastic pellets around
the world.
PC bees are are linked to
reproductive disorders increased
risk of disease altering hormone
levels in an organism and
ultimately contributing directly
to death.
And and noticed that the the
concentrations globally tend to
be well below a hundred PC bees --
Plastic --
Pallets per area but look at San
Francisco and Los Angeles as two
of the highest --
Areas of concentration of these
P. P. C..
P. skews me PCB laden pallets
that and that mostly and up on
coastal beaches --
And importantly it's the
contaminants that are in the
plastics themselves but also
realize that plastics in here
other contaminants.
And make those available --
When they're to organisms when
they're ingested as well next
slide please --
In an annex or a and an example
of that specifically because
much of this stuff ends up on
beaches.
Is that it gets and consumed by
all the all organisms that live
within the the sandy beach area --
Which in turn are the major pray
for many of the shore birds
along the coast so this is the
primary means by which plastic
contaminants.
Ultimately end up in birds like
the greater share water through
those what are called truth
thick --
Interactions the consumption of
prey that are are on
contaminated to start with.
Next slide please.
And then that leads to other
indirect consequences.
As this stuff accumulates on
beaches like beach rack kelp
does as well.
We go through --
Great efforts to remove it and
clean it from the beach but that
process itself actually disrupts
that ecosystem.
I mentioned all the organisms
that live in those sandy beaches
and when we go through and
constantly just wrapped and
removed --
That that San we impact the
communities of organisms that
live in the sand which again are
wet those shore birds and other
species are dependent upon.
And finally --
A really important --
Consequence of plastic is as
what is referred to of actor a
transport factor of invasive
species and this is because that
those plastics can move great
distances.
Clearly from one side of the
Pacific as we've seen from --
Fukushima.
And as those plastics move they
get colonized by organisms they
transport those organisms to new
places.
That naturally would not.
Get to and as a consequence
there a means of transporting
invasive species which then can
alter communities at the
recipient --
Ecosystems.
So these are the the five
primary ways that these various
contaminants are all terrain --
Population individual organisms
populations communities and
entire ecosystems.
Through these different kinds of
interactions.
And I think that's it for me.
Having been the Debbie Downer of
the panel.
Great thank you and I think what
we'll do is have each.
First on the panel presents and
then open it up for questions
from.
Assembly member [inaudible]
Great.
Whether pulling up my slides my
name's Amy wohl from I'm from
the Monterey Bay aquarium I do
California ocean policy work
there at the aquarium or here.
In the bay in the world.
And one moment please.
Air I am so I am here today to
share with Monterey Bay aquarium
has gotten involved to help
reduce ocean plastic pollution
and to understand more about the
impact it's having on the health
of the ocean as well as our
fresh water wildlife and
ecosystems.
The problem of plastic pollution
becomes more vivid every day as
a growing body of research is
revealing how ubiquitous plastic
has become in nature.
And points to help businesses
usual approach means more and
more plastic will enter the
environment in years to come.
On the positive side of this
issue is solvable.
And as attention on it grows so
does innovation in the public
and private sector to move us to
new more sustainable directions.
Many of you have likely seen
images of plastic soups like
this one an even more disturbing
photos of marine animals.
I won't show days today but
images like these have captured
the public attention and started
a global movement to prevent
plastic pollution [inaudible]
Next slide.
This issue.
Has definitely captured the
attention of our visitors based
on a two thousand eighteen
survey over half of our visitors
view plastic pollution is the
biggest threat to ocean health
and see taking action on this
issue is a key key way to help
the ocean.
There are also been statewide
surveys of California voters on
this issue that showed that a
majority of them are concerned
about the impacts of plastic
pollution.
On our beaches and waterways.
In fact a majority vote voters
here in California res rejected
a ballot proposal to appeal
California's first in the nation
statewide plastic bag law.
And we also saw the passage of
AB eighteen eighty four straws
on request.
Next slide.
Media outlets like National
Geographic can the sciences
story of plastic pollution front
and center in the public eye.
Grassroots an NGO led campaigns
on the issue continue to
proliferate and now there are
signs that heightened awareness
by the public many of whom are
consumers of plastic is
inspiring change from the local
to global level.
Next slide.
And what impact does all this
plastic pollution having on
marine life.
Next slide.
Scientists report that there's
been an increase in the number
of incidences between plastic
and marine animals either by
entanglement or ingestion as we
just heard from professor car.
That sometimes leads to
mortality otherwise known as
death.
Nearly seven hundred marines
beaches have been impacted by
plastic over half of all
individual sea turtles have
ingested plastic.
And it's estimated that by.
Twenty twenty five or twenty
fifty excuse me 95% of all sea
birds live in just a plastic.
Plastic is also affected at
least twenty six species of
cetaceans including the pilot
well found struggling to swim in
a tie can now this past June.
Any Cropsey animal autopsy
showed that it had seventeen
pounds of plastic and stomach
that made it impossible for the
well to ingest food.
An important area of future
researches help plastic impacts
these animals at the population
level.
Both today and into the future
as the volume of plastic
pollution grows.
Another attribute of most
plastic that is problematic or
next yep thank you.
The another attribute of most
plastic that is problematic for
the environment is that it does
not biodegrade under natural
conditions.
They can break down into smaller
and smaller pieces particles
less than five millimeters in
size or referred to as Michael
plastic.
Other types of Michael plastic
like micro national waste
management devices and flow into
the water waste and land.
Recent studies demonstrate that
were only beginning to scratch
the surface of the prevalence of
Michael plastic in the ocean and
its impact.
We know that it can spread
throughout the water column.
From service to see floor and
that organisms as small as
plankton can ingest Michael
plastic before being eaten by
fish and other animals higher up
the food chain.
We want to learn more about this
bioaccumulation of fact
especially considering the
plastic can contain toxic
chemicals that may be absorbed
into the tissues of marine
organisms.
There's a lot we still have to
learn about these processes and
so far many in the scientific
community.
Said the plastic in seafood for
example does not yet pose a
significant risk to human health.
The more plastic that enters the
ocean food web though the
greater the urgency for
answering these types of
important questions.
So what is the solution to the
growing passed a pollution
problem if there's anything
positive to say about such a
broad and complex challenges
that there are lots of actions.
Each of us can take to close the
gap between protect production
of plastic and recovery of it.
And stem the flow of plastic
into our ocean.
The two over arching solutions
the solutions strategies that in
for my work at the aquarium our
first.
We have to turn down the Tanpa
we deal with the mass.
This means we need to address
source reduction at the same
time is we would prove waste
management especially in the
countries that are quote leaking
the most plastic into the ocean.
Number two now is a great time
to innovate ways we can move
from a linear lifecycle for
plastic.
The one to one that keeps the
plastic we need the most in use
for as long as possible.
On living away from unnecessary
single use.
Monterey Bay aquarium is leading
a consortium of twenty two
aquariums across the United
States brought together to
increase our collective impact
on ocean conservation.
The partnership is adopted
plastic pollution as its primary
goal and last year all members
aquariums pledge to live
immediately eliminate all
plastic straws for my food
service.
And take away bags from our gift
shops and significantly reduce
or eliminate plastic beverage
bottles by.
Twenty twenty Monterey Bay
aquarium has already phase that
are single use bottles along
with other single use plastic
items in our front of the house
food service operations.
Were also working with their
food and retail service provider
to reduce single use plastic in
our gift store.
We know this is an easy and
that's why we are champion of
business and government working
to make incremental change.
In the right direction we hope
the more committed we are to
change the more new and
innovative solutions will emerge
to solve the problem of ocean
plastic pollution for good.
Thank you for the opportunity to
speak with you today.
Thank you.
These.
Good morning thank you for
having me here today --
I'm all the wire and the marine
pollution program manager at the
California ocean protection
council --
And as the finder coming up I
just to provide you got to the
brief background on who the
agent protection council is --
What we are a state agency this
sort of nested within the
natural resources agency --
And we work to protect the ocean
for current and future
generations --
We working for me in ways we
recommend and implement policy.
Abby leading promote
coordination among state
agencies.
Mistaken leverage funding for
research and making with the
best available science.
The OPC has been working on
plastic pollution since --
Two thousand seven and today
I'll be talking about some of
our more recent work on the
issue --
Before I died into what we see
is been doing I know we've heard
a lot about ecological impact of
plastic and I wanted to briefly
mention the economic impact of
plastic the California --
Into twenty fifteen California
communities were spending more
than four hundred twenty eight
million per year to clean up and
control letter --
And in addition to that a lot of
the litter cleanups are done
using volunteers which cost them
their time --
In the volunteer service --
The California adopt a highway
participants is estimated at
eighteen million annually.
Enjoy this cost the state a lot
of money --
So how are we going about
addressing this issue.
A and I'm going to cover if you
policy initiatives today and the
first is a twenty eighteen
notion that our strategy and
then I'll take a few minutes to
talk about the trash amendments
and packaging reform.
Other twenty eighteen session
letter strategy outlines OPC
priorities and stakeholder
actions to address social
lettering California over the
next six years --
And I just one other plastic
pollution of the multi faceted
problems of the strategy include
action that a really wide
variety of skills and scopes --
Essentially because no one
solution is really going to just
be the silver bullet that's all
all of this --
So we want to include a wide
range of which and annex side
please.
Overall the strategy has
prioritized source reduction as
the most effective and least
costly.
Costly method to reduce plastic
pollution.
And we define this as practices
that reduce the amount of
materials entering the waste
stream am including changes in
the design manufacture or a
purchase or use of materials.
Next slide please.
Organizations can engage in
source reduction at multiple
points in the product life cycle --
Including making changes in the
design institutional purchasing --
And distribution of items that
commonly become plastic
pollution --
In addition to this when you're
sort of decision points model --
Governments can also make broad
changes to waste management that
encourage source reduction on a
large scale.
And for example implementing
policies that will produce or to
responsible for the end of life
management --
And disposal ideally recycling
or reuse of their products next
by please.
As part of the initial letter
strategy the OPC is developed as
priorities to address social
letter --
And today it I've we have three
categories listed out here --
In today and really just going
to focus on the first one of
land based sources division
letter.
This means --
Product to be calmly find that's
rappers that sort of thing --
The uppity has identified --
Number priority actions to
address this and I can't go
through all of them but a few of
them include permitting changes
and state purchasing and service
contracts to get combination
letter items --
Out of the dining facilities and
state buildings --
Promoting comprehensive waste
management approaches to prevent
the production of combination
letter items through cal
recycles packaging reform
efforts.
On and supporting policies that
reduce expanded polystyrene
letter --
Such as a provision in single
use food service where --
Or including inclusion of
expanded polystyrene in college
like of packaging reform efforts.
Under to provide a little bit
more background on this OPC
included --
Expanded polystyrene began in
our two two thousand eight
letters prodigy.
And we've included in the twenty
eight to twenty eighteen
document for a few reasons --
The first is that when expanded
polystyrene gets into
environment it breaks into
little pieces very quickly --
And it often mixes into sand and
sediments that's very hard to
clean up.
And in its use as part of and
recyclable you can technically
recycled perfectly clean
polystyrene phone but once it's
contaminated food you really
just have to go and felt --
So that's part of why we're
continuing to prioritize if a
policy action.
Annex I please --
As I mentioned there's not a
company there is in the silver
bullet to address the issue of
plastic pollution --
So we're taking comprehensive
approach and working with --
Other state agencies I'm going
to briefly touch on a couple of
different policies that the
state's working on and how we're
working with them.
And the first I'd like to talk
about is the trash amendments
and these are amendments that
prohibits storm water systems.
From just charging trash larger
than by millimeters to waters of
the state.
On the trusted amendments were
adopted by the state water board
in twenty fifteen and we're now
in the early stages of
implementation --
And as part of that local
governments are deciding how to
comply. One thing the truck
commitment has done is is that
is taken the costs associated
with uncontrolled.
Uncontrolled trash and has made
that explicit --
So local government are having
to pay for a full capture system
to catch this trash or they're
having to pay for a number of
other measures that would be
equivalent installing a full
capture system.
We're interested in how the
action the policies recommended
in the letter strategy could
potentially help to bring those
costs to local governments down --
For example if a local
government fan something like
expanded polystyrene they no
longer have to worry about
cleaning it out of there
catchments and there are
starving systems --
In addition to this we a PC is
also committed to exploring a
priority action of on looking at
methods for producers and the
public to share responsibility
to fund the cleanup of beaches
in a lot of ways that are
polluted with.
Different types of plastic
products --
So now I'm going to move to
packaging form of this is an
effort that is currently being
undertaken by cover cycle to
develop recommendations for how
the state.
Should proceed with a mandatory
approach to decrease the
generation of packaging waste
and I'm and increase packaging
reuse recycling and composting --
This will include pretty sure
taking increased responsibility
for the end of life their
packaging.
A part of like our cycles taking
this on is that California has
that some very aggressive waste
diversion goals.
And packaging makes up about a
quarter of the way streaming
California which is why it's a
priority for cover cycle to
address.
Most of the items that are
commonly found as plastic
pollution fall under this broad
category of packaging the cover
cycle is looking at I'm in the
stakeholders at we worked with
on the letter strategy are
really interested in using
packaging reform to promote and
achieve more comprehensive
source reduction.
Of plastic pollution --
As part of the strategy OPC is
committed to finding a report
that would synthesize lessons
learned from waste management
policies and tools and other
countries --
It and develop recommendations
for California with a focus on
how to use those policies
policies for source reduction --
The annex I please.
Taken cleared I just like to add
that we're at the beginning of
the strategy implementation
process --
And that its intended to six
years and we're excited to move
the city forward [inaudible]
Great.
Thank you all so much --
Just kind of a start of
questions and the next panel is
going to look a little bit more
at some of the details a bit
more locally but okay OPC even
those California based of the
seas done a very good job of
building some linkages.
Internationally on issues that
you're familiar with the
aquarium of course is an
international organization and
sits between.
In a lot of ways government and
industry since governments
regulating industry producing
the aquarium as a non
governmental organization I
think is a tremendous amount of
influence it has done a lot
around the world.
And then of course.
Our university system as
represented here by professor
car.
Doing a lot of research and sort
of looking globally I've I
looked at the slides that you
had Dr Kerr this is a question
actually.
For for any of you.
And some of the other.
Data that I've shown is that yes
the US produces a lot of plastic
China there some sources of
plastic.
But if you look at the rivers
that are the major conduits for
plastics a lot of those are in
Southeast Asia.
South America and other places.
Sealed my question is so what
for for us of California does
plastic policy are we really
going to have.
That big of an impact on the
amount of plastics that into the
ocean.
So I'll I'll take the first shot
at responding to that. To the
work that is --
Looked at the at the
distribution of that of marine
debris.
Has shown that it's very
strongly where it's produced --
And so so.
While we may not affect the
production of marine debris
generated by China --
If we reduce them right amount
of marine debris that's
generated in the United States
that'll have a direct impact.
On marine debris here and a
bright because it's it's being
restricted. To those areas where
it's it's largely generated.
The other --
Evidence of that is it if you
look across all the basins the
ocean basins around the world.
The ocean basin that by far has
the greatest amount of marine
debris is the north Pacific
because it's it lies between
China and the United States so
that combined production and
disposal of of waste material by
our two countries.
Have led to the greatest
concentrate globally.
In an offer because thank you
other comes from palace
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Hang on what we can.
Still instrument.
Embodying.
McCarty I mean that that was I
will admit that was a loaded
question [inaudible]
Okay okay I recommend that we
focus on these issues from the
whole state of California is the
ocean especially areas where I
represent Sacramento we have.
Freaks the stranger have.
Annual cleanups there we could
see it first hand W. said how
how the plastic that gets into
the ocean is mainly land base as
opposed to marines apart.
So that from letter or mistakes
people not discarding their
their their recycles properly or
maybe they do and it just falls
off the trash truck and go so
how does it.
How does it?
In a picture of how it all goes
sideways.
I think it's it's very difficult
to pinpoint about level whether
someone that actually just
intentionally through it on the
ground versus someone to put it
in the trash can and then it
fell out of the trash can lid
being picked up and put into a
truck or something --
That level of detail is hard to
pin down --
But I think it's characterizing
all of as intentional littering
really isn't accurate a lot of
the things that we find the call
to clean up their relatively
small.
They're easy to lose track of
and so I don't think that
intentional littering is.
The bulk of the problem.
But to reinforce whether
intentional or not it is letter.
And that is the primary source
of this.
Material that ends up.
In the fresh water systems in --
Systems and then ultimately is
transported to the ocean.
Getting at some point is that
we're doing a great job
recycling trying their best but
you know it happens right makes
up and stuff.
Fall through the cracks the
winning that struck me to the
show.
The amount of recycling maybe
where the percentage of product
is that we're recycling.
Is significant but the amount of
volume so much greater than it
was twenty years ago exactly
that and then maybe while we
increase recycling participation
by. 70% last twenty years would
be look at the actual piece
right in that.
In the water ways it's it's
worse than decades ago right so
what are some of the what are
some of the and we'll get to
this next but from your
perspective. Three what are some
of the potential remedies that
we see in.
States jurisdictions across the
globe.
They can --
They can address this.
So all start and then you two
can certainly take off on this
but as both of of panelists
emphasized its the source it's
the production of the material.
Right that if if there is a way
to curb the amount of plastic
material that we consume that we
use then that will be the most
significant way to reduce the
amount of material that.
Ends up in the ocean.
And by far that's it's going
right at the source of the
problem that is probably the
strongest solution --
And then the other activities of
of the amount of recycling like
you said the amount of recycling
we do --
Efforts to manage that material
better --
Those will help but yeah and
it's all a function of just how
much of this stuff we're having
to cope with it unit that's easy
to say but what what does that
mean in practical terms for a
family [inaudible]
Our family.
Not might be my wife for two
little girls [inaudible]
By.
You know food and products.
To you no washer closer laundry
and so forth so we're buying
just consumption of stock.
Does it is it choices that we're
making the things differently or
is it.
Requiring manufacture things
differently regarding to produce
you know biodegradable
containers that are so aye based
don't nine what.
What are the?
Are the best solution.
It I think it's gonna there's a
lot of different ways we got
into the problem with plastic
being around everything that we
use so I think there's a lot of
families were going to get out
of it so it is.
It is both --
Consumers.
Making the choices with their
pocketbooks with their wallets
and deciding what they're going
to buy which will send a signal
to the market that we we don't
want everything wrapped in
single use plastic all the time
it's also.
Things like the legislation that
we've just passed around single
reducing the use of straws as
well as requiring that packaging
be either recycling.
Recyclable are composed ball as
state facilities so there are
different ways and I think that
we Ana on a more global.
Macro level of looking at our
markets we to our businesses
that we need some different
choices there's not a a as Holly
said a silver bullet right now
there's not it.
No one's invented --
A new kind of less problematic
plastic just yet however.
We can work towards those types
of solutions.
I just wanted to add that on
there is I think a role for
packaging redesign and source
reduction a lot of what we find
and beaches are things like
bottle caps --
And if you can attach caps the
bottle so that you don't end up
having this lease cap on to you
you know twisted off your model.
It's a great way.
To prevent that from getting was
in the environment --
I know Assemblymember's down as
authored some bills are not in
the past [inaudible]
The Friedman.
I have two questions the first
is --
Regulatory when an American ship
or California ship were voter
any vessel goes to see. To we
have control over it regulatory
relief once it gets outside of
U. S. waters.
Or they just can do whatever
they want because they're no
longer in U. S. waters to use
you and if you don't know that's
fine we can find out.
Anybody now I do not no I I
unfortunately do not know ninety
my account of that's something
I'm curious about.
And secondly I'm wondering if
any of you know of any analysis
of cost I'm thinking about
beverage bottles particularly
beverage containers of cost
between glass and plastic.
And how that analysis breaks
down you know including
transportation and everything
else that.
The manufacturer the the
bottlers have or have any data
that's nobody did I don't expect
it answer the question right now.
But you know of any data that's
available on that.
You know I don't know whether
that's been there's been
analyses for then I suspect the
next panel members.
May be able to respond to that
better actually okay and TM.
What is that?
The couple repairers ships are
US flag there is some
jurisdiction over a shift that
is in international waters that
is moving to the United States
ships that are not US flag there
is no guard little or no
jurisdiction.
So if there's an accident or a
dumping of classics very little
we can do about it.
If that ship is on its way into
US port there might be.
More that can happen but once it
to U. S. B. ship to they have to
follow our rules even if they're
in international waters it yes
of its US flag.
It is but most of the commerce
is with ships that are not US
[inaudible]
Five this car.
Thank you for the quick
questions --
To the you know by I think a lot
of this has to do both market
based upon demand it also --
Dave your change --
Regulation can for some of that
and I was very product number
and found that it was on the
council we're the first big city
to ban.
Single use plastic of all for
all retail --
And we saw the results of that
the band --
Polystyrene for take out --
The restaurants adapted very
quickly and customers
appreciated it --
And so.
In that same vein.
What as as we look at the
regulatory side of a what of how
we can force the issue?
Because of the scale and the
scope of the problem I think is
waiting and waiting for a market
based solution --
Isn't good enough --
End.
Waiting just for individual
behavior change when people are
making consumer families witness
who decisions.
Yeah they might want to try to
do the right thing as much as
they can but and the day.
They they have a limitation on
how much they can pay for things
and it the costs are skewed.
Towards more by really friendly.
Being more expensive and then
there needs to be --
Some kind of up impact on market
forces and so for this panel as
well as the next may have some
insight on this --
Are there.
Technologies --
In and and send a card to touch
on a little bit other some
technologies.
Alternatives to plastics that
we're seeing that our scalable
yet or we just because I know
that there are some.
Builders are starting to make
some bottles at our plant days
to stardom a surly make utensils
what have you but I I don't
believe it's scalable to the to
the extent regular place.
Plastic production and does
regulation help get us there in
terms of forcing the issue to
create.
That demand but because that's
where the supply side innovation
oftentimes comes from
[inaudible]
You can. Two of the ecologists
will respond --
If.
The is an excellent question and
you nailed it on the head --
This question of of where do you
where do the consumer behavior --
Solutions lie verses the
regulatory the incentives and
disincentives lie and so that
analysis I think is critical --
And there are other fields
fisheries management which is
when I work in more --
Is really looks at the the
potential importance of consumer
decisions and where those are
most effective rather relative
to regulatory actions.
On but I think the are you
Asians that are emerging now are
in fact scalable.
And the the question is how do
you scale them do you use that
mechanism of consumer behavior.
And or do you use the regulatory.
And imagine might be a
combination of both Alexakis
wait for one or the other by
itself and then --
Another another note that it
seems quite apparent that it's
really smaller plastics are
plastic that are broken down
into smaller pieces are causing.
An enormous issues that just.
But this really is laws --
Operationally it's easier to
capture.
Last night with water damage
control and sounds a we have the
scrubbers and you can see.
It's picking up these larger
pieces but clearly you know it
it's bottle caps are small those
the what does of the items that
have a greater chance.
Of of following through so I
agree that --
Kind of focusing on ways to cut
back on the need for some of
those smaller plastics as summer
stone is worked on and I know
that --
There may be other areas in
terms of the kind of plastics it
that's used its ability to be
able to break down exacerbate
existing intact.
I I think --
Would have an impact certainly
on the oceans.
Your first question I know there
are -- Some
innovation centers in California
and that are doing materials
innovation for plastic
alternatives --
To the best of my knowledge none
of those are scalable yet but it
is an ongoing area of research
and there's a lot of interest.
And I think there's not a lot of
answers on the micro.
Plastics issue because there's
it's a brand new issue and I
think a lot a lot of research
necessarily but the fact that
they're finding micro.
Plastics in bottled water
people's blood streams lots of
places that are alarming is
something that.
The is an issue we need to be
talking about.
An end what's interesting as
well from you you referred
correctly to the straw bale that
it's more of a straw options
bill.
But the power of even though
that's and options bill the
power of having the conversation.
There are.
People across the country that
are very worried about the straw
band that came out of California.
And the more they're talking
about it is a strong bad starts
to have the desired effect of
making people think about
whether they want. To use straws
or not in fact we were in a
restaurant last night and
offered straws that we were told
not plastic its cellulose.
It wasn't it was plastic.
But the there's lots of
confusion but it is interesting
just having a conversation and
and the opportunity for people
to take some responsibility and
and some awareness.
I think that's one of the
biggest impacts that we can have
by having these conversations.
Yeah but we also have to be
careful of how it's interpreted
I'm I was really happy to hear
that Starbucks was moving away
from any classics Ross anywhere
in the country.
With a lot less thrilled about
that when I found out they were
individually wrapping all of
their paper straws in plastic.
Which they are have in which
they are doing and so on is not
I guess the message got
partially there but yeah.
That's interesting I I had.
Right other questions from the
assembly members.
I think we'll move on that thank
you very much to this panel that
was very interesting and will
call up.
It'll be.
After today from save our shores
Tim guns rob from Santa Cruz
County and Charles hug from
Republic services.
Please come and join us.
Is.
This your power plants
[inaudible]
Yes of everybody and see if --
The best the best [inaudible]
Unless a Waldron member Reginald.
Welcome so again with they would
similarly just have the analyst
give us their their perspectives
on next steps that will will go
in order. For the day Mister
nonprofit Mister how good.
So please welcome.
The morning everyone and thank
you assembly member stone and
McCarty --
For inviting me here to speak
this is a subject that's very
near and dear to my heart as
it's something that we work in
every day --
I also have a strong background
in plastics and plastic
pollution having worked.
For almost ten years --
With an organization called.
Which is a spin off of eco
designer bill McDonough for
those of you may know that name --
Is so I've worked a long time on
issues of plastic especially
with the plastic --
Packaging sector --
But that's another story so they
will stay focused on weight
saver shorts is doing --
Next slide please --
Probably knew all of you from
Santa Cruz and even though it's
from other parts of the state
may know then savor Chaudhry's.
It's been around for forty years
now this is our fortieth
anniversary and we've been
protecting being marine
ecosystem along the central
coast and particularly within
the boundaries of that.
Monterey Bay national marine
sanctuary for those forty years
for decades we've worked on
everything from the original oil
and gas drilling threat which
we've now come full circle in
our dressing again under.
A small T. little any trump
administration --
We are have also don't with.
Cruise ships marine acoustics --
More recently the plastic
pollution we've dealt with sand
mining on your insurance and we
take on most issues that affect
that the health and well being
of our coastal environment.
Next line --
Last year two thousand seven we
came out with a new vision
twenty twenty five and strategy
that will guide our work for at
least the next ten years and
possibly beyond.
And when the strategy process we
asked what conditions would we
need to have a thriving Monterey
Bay and we came up with the
three pillars.
That are guiding our strategies
and tactics the habitats and
living waters of course plastic
pollution affects all three of
those conditions next.
So it the problem which is
really become a crisis and I
think it's elevated to the point
of crisis on a global level next
line.
So back in the nineteen fifties
plastics were first introduced
into the world to and this is a
picture from life magazine.
Some of you were old enough to
remember that publication many
probably not --
And that this was you know like
wow all excited American how his
wife you're going to be.
Free from washing dishes and
making food and everything else
we had plastics and processed
food came on the market and life
is good and wonderful and in
sort of a convenience mindset
really took hold to the consumer
inconvenience mindsets next.
But today we see a whole
different picture we've gone and
sort of these roughly sixty
sixty five years from a love
affair with plastics.
To heed affair with plastic in
in you know major super concern
around the globe and protests
and you know people demanding
that we take action on this
crisis that's taken over.
Our globin in particular our
most important resource the
ocean.
Next.
So packaging is really sort of
the poster child for our current
economic system in consumer --
Economy which is basically a
take make waste systems very
winning your we take resources
from the earth we turn it into a
product we use it often for a
very brief period of time.
And we just throw it away except
there is no away --
This is actually a can of what I
think is the sad state of
recycling especially in this
country we have probably one of
the worst --
Recycling rates in the world
even though we are one of the
most highly technologically
involved countries --
You can see here 78% of the U.
S. waste stream could be
recycled that means there are
actually.
Techniques and across the seas
that can recycle that material
but we're only recycling around
30% in that 30%.
Is rounded up it's like --
Twenty seven again so we've gone
from love to hate and here are
some of the reasons why you know
we have eight million metric
tons of plastic going into or
ocean.
Every year we have --
Two point five billion metric
tons of solid waste produced
around the world every year --
It you know there's one study
out there that.
Not really tongue in cheek but I
think not entirely accurate me I
either because we actually don't
know how many fish are in the
scene but there's a study out
there that says by twenty fifty
if we keep on the path we're
going to be more plastic than
fish.
Inner ocean --
Master here some later
statistics from our data
collection needs are twenty
seventeen numbers.
We see cigarette* you sure --
Up at the top and for those of
you who don't know that is the
plastic litter problem it's not
a paper filter it's made of a
polymer.
They don't know exactly assembly
but it's it's plastic pollution
all those cigarette* we see.
And I think that those are.
Maybe not intended an instances
of later but certainly
thoughtless instances of later
where people test.
Done throw it.
And we learned behavior for
movies and TV and you know
everything for your for decades
and decades --
Yes let's get to the solutions
which you know I think that has
a lot to do with smart policy.
So our theory of change and save
our shores is based on awareness
advocacy in action and those are
the primary ways that we drive
positive change.
So often you know --
Our role is to make people aware
of the issue and where of some
of the solutions in ways that
they can change their behavior
we to a lot of that through
formal education.
We believe you know we have an
opportunity to teach the next
generation not.
To climb onto the convenience
lifestyle --
To better understand that there
is no one way when we throw
things away that there is --
Consequences and soon bill
generations that have a greater
environmental ethics and then we
did in previous generations --
Advocacy --
We ever local lawmakers that
city level regional county level
and state level --
And we had a lot of success and
sort of driving some of these
policies to to be enacted
especially in our local
communities.
Inter action you know all of it
is action really but we also are
able to turn out literally
thousands like eleven thousand
volunteers the year to help us.
Do our education and outreach
support or advocacy work in a
lot of it to come out and clean
up our shores we had.
Over three thousand volunteers
came out for one day on annual
coastal cleanup day which is
also international coastal
cleanup day.
In removed well over eleven
thousand pounds of trash and
like three hours that one day
next.
So some packaging bands that
save our shores started without
the local level ways.
Able to get past in the in many
of our incorporated cities and
Santa Cruz in Monterey county as
well as the counties themselves --
You know we've had polystyrene
band going back from. To the
twenty ten to one talk more
about that some just gonna kind
of glossed over that for now
also plastic bags we were when
in the first.
Communities Santa Cruz and
Monterey county center and
incorporated areas that.
Did a plastic bag band and I
think we got something like
fifty six ordinances passed in
local regional area and then as
we see that became a state wide
success story.
Anna.
Sort of attacked by citizen
support to make sure that we
kept that law on the books and
we're the only state that has it.
And then --
We expanded our poly styrene
ordinance in sap is Santa Cruz
County to include other to go
food service where like straw is --
Non recyclable are nine composed
Monique you.
On the Philippines.
When you meet with?
You can thank you --
In even stronger see we actually
know what the state law.
An option bill or whatever you
call it in sacks Santa Cruz
really do have a straw man is
now in supposed to go.
We can't.
Give it out if it's not
recyclable and compostable and
then in the restaurants no it
has to be on demand so in effect
we have a strong band here next
[inaudible]
Of so --
Policy work really does pay
office you can see.
On the left --
Poly styrene numbers in two
thousand eight before we had any
kind of the ordinances we're
about.
Yes significant levels of trash
collected.
Going down down down.
320-122-01314 across the board
in or download data collection
is in the normally where it has
gone back up but we think this
is a two year is where we did.
We started our extreme clean up
pro.
Some of the caves and other you
know areas along the shores that
are hard to access up into the
rocks and boulders more into the
dunes and working with --
Even the am U. S. navy and
cleaning some of their doing
sites are we would get out.
Yeah probably twenty five
thousand pounds of trash from
homeless camps to just abandon
stuff for years and years and
years.
And then you know after extreme
cleanups cleanup so went down
you can see we're back to pretty
low levels of poly styrene --
Mostly what we see here now
chunks of it links probably from
coolers and always sorts of
things.
And then --
In terms of bags it's a really
clear.
Success in terms of how policy
helps and smart policy works.
We didn't even have the bump up
in the twenty thirteen twenty
fourteen when you were doing are
extreme cleanups.
Next.
So going forward we have some
ambitious plans on the local
level --
Which we hope will eventually go
up to the state level we have
six items that were targeting
right now and we have already
approach thingy --
Board of supervisors in Santa
Cruz and the city council in
Santa Cruz will be reaching out
to the other incorporated areas
and Santa Cruz probably before
the end of this week and into
monitoring.
Next week and what we're asking
for is.
Some kind of a solution for the
six problem so we have the tiny
little toiletry bottles and
we've all seen in hotels.
They hardly even ever get used
even if they do they're not for
we used all of that is put into
the trash every day thousands of
bottles.
Much of industry is already
starting to move in the
direction of eliminating those
in favor of of well known and
dispensers we have asked.
For an ordinance in Santa Cruz
County in the city and we will
be in to these other
jurisdictions.
That the use of those in the
hospitality industry be banned
in favor of one mounted.
Really pleased to say we have a
board of super this initiative
and the county.
In will probably on an ordinance
by the end of the year.
In the company of the will is.
What might be fun actually
playing no real needed purpose
and world --
It yet you know they cause a lot
of problems in terms of being
let go drifting in New York
oceans and tangled the
stuttering cetera --
Also ingestion where scan for a
ban on the sale balloons on in
the county.
And we will start with the mylar
balloons which are actually more
problematic than simple latex
but we'd like to see them all.
Eliminated.
Contact lenses and interesting
when it came on our radar screen
only about a month and a half
two months Max ago and this was
as a result of a study that came
out I of all people the American
chemistry council.
And keep sort of playing with
why would they put the study out
and the only reason I can think
of is to takes are to blame on
industry or the focus off of
industry as the problem and put
it on consumers as the problem
because the issue here is.
That one out of five users of
the daily disposables.
Question down the toilet.
We don't want that to happen
because the water treatment
facilities can't deal with that
their screens at Saturn not
small enough to collect and send
these training at all.
Maker plastic products.
On their way for plastics even
in their full state or being fly
straight into our waterways and
inter ocean.
In becoming you know we we're
not seeing it so much nobody's.
Reporting the pick up of contact
lenses honor they're so we'd
like some kind of a take back.
Current extended producer
responsibility long time to deal
with not taking contacts and we
from people for sure.
On the giving them away to take
them back to drop them off and
have the manufacturing deal with
them.
Micro fibers is kind of the
newest thing on the radar screen
this is little pieces sort of
like --
Strand of hair that just flops
off your Palmer base closings --
Every time that you wash it and
so is simple solution there is
installation of filters on
washing machines --
You know even the more expensive
ones are only about a hundred
and fifty dollars so we're
asking that.
All commercial laundry
facilities which would be the
laundry service says laundromats
dry cleaners --
Hospitality industry that still
does their own laundry and
apartment complexes with
multiple laundry machines
install filters on them so that
we can begin to stop the flow of
that through our waterways and
into the ocean.
Hi too many people today can't
as a convenience have have
bought your rank and espresso
coffee tape machines were you
put in a little tiny get you one
Cup of coffee.
You just dump the pod and in the
trash.
And those are not recyclable
learning compostable and its
first --
Does have a take back program so
we're not targeting without
those pod so much but the pods
that are not recyclable are
composed of only blank ban on
the sale of those.
In our community and then the
whole the plastic bottles --
We know that in our communities
most people are already using
reusable drinking containers.
Nine is we want to finally put a
stop to the sale of those single
use.
The water bottles anything under
a gallon [inaudible]
And if I were clean it when
being all beverage bottles all
plastic beverage bottles but
when we can put out hydration
stations for people to go water
we can't necessarily put them
out for people that.
We fail a coke or juice or
something mobile for you.
And Katharine for queen here --
So I'm gonna wrap it up there --
And if you have any morning join
our campaign just contact me.
Clean ups you can contact air.
Volunteer so she it and then you
know check out our website for
what else we're doing thank you
[inaudible]
Thank you.
This without her.
What we're waiting for the
presentational out I thought I'd
ask?
How many of you came here from
out of town today?
Quite a few.
Well if you look around and as
you ride you can see.
Why were so Phillies fiercely
protective of our local
environment here we have?
A lot at stake.
And it's one of the big reasons
why so many.
Innovations environmental
protection began right here in
Santa Cruz County.
And I'm gonna share a few of
those with you today.
Next slide please.
We a one of the most
comprehensive environmental
education programs in this
county that you'll find.
Anywhere.
Every child in school yes
education in.
Elementary school and beyond.
They all learn to recycle it
practices every day at school
they all learn about.
Composting their food waste many
of them get to work in their
school gardens and learn about
the benefits of compost.
We have a program through on
you'll see us see where children
can.
Go out on a boat on the bay.
And actually take up samples
look at plankton under a
microscope and see for
themselves.
The plastic pollution in our
waters and learn about the
impacts of that.
So they get a very thorough
understanding.
Of how the way that they live
their lives affects the
environment around them.
And that's something that they
carry with them as they go
through life [inaudible]
Next line.
We also do a lot to educate the
general public we have
newsletters that go out to every
home and business several times
year.
We have constant ads in the
print media.
On TV and on radio if your local
you probably hear these.
Every day urging people not to
litter remember to recycle and
other versions of that and one
of the challenges that all of us
in coastal communities in
particular have is.
How do we educate the the hordes
of visitors that we get
especially in the summer?
About respecting our local
environment and what you see on
the lower left there.
Is an experiment we tried a few
years ago using our buses as
rolling billboards.
And we had San and similar ones
at on buses all over the county
you could hardly miss them they
were.
Controversy all but to me that
that was a good thing they got
people's attention.
Next slide please.
Hey.
As was mentioned earlier we are
facing such a tsunami of plastic.
That all our best efforts at
recycling are not enough we have
to go after the source.
And we have done that in
numerous ways locally and in the
twenty but a few of those next.
Poly styrene as was mentioned.
It is a very difficult product
to recycle properly.
Because it's so frequently
contaminated with food residue.
Because of its lightweight its
bulky miss it's low value.
Economically and logistically
just rarely makes sense to
recycle if.
So as Catherine mentioned.
There's a taper.
Off excellent.
In -- Two
thousand eight senators county
was among the first to prohibit
the use of styrofoam and food
service.
But we were still seeing it our
parks on our beaches serve few
years later we took the next
step.
Of saying are you cancel the
stuff in our county anymore is
people were going to the store
and buying styrofoam cooler
styrofoam cups other similar
products.
Taking it to the beach and
leaving it there.
We very rarely see that anymore
as Catherine mansion.
Prohibiting retail sales of poly
styrene from products.
Has.
Almost completely solve that
problem next please.
Plastic bags Chen Cruz County
was among the very first. To
initiate a ban on single use
plastic bags --
Because there was so little
track record we weren't really
sure what the impact is going to
be so we sent teams out to local
shopping areas to monitor.
Our people handling this are
they getting paper bags of the
they buying bags are they doing
with our they bring in their own.
We found the remarkably within
thirty days of the effective
date of that ordinance.
More than 90% of local shoppers
were bringing their own backs.
As in Santa of in a mitigation --
For we had some wonderful
reusable bags made a here's an
example it said.
Organic cotton that.
Grounded manufactured in the US
made with non VOC a stack of
these are in the back of the
room so please help yourself to
learn on their way out it's the
best shopping bag you'll ever
had.
We've given out thousands of
these.
M. by our estimate we've reduce
the use of single use plastic
bags just in this little county.
By a hundred million bags a year
[inaudible]
Thanks.
For as Catherine mentioned --
Last year we took another
significant step --
We told our food service
businesses from now on
everything you.
Is guided the recyclable or
compostable.
Enemies recyclable by our
standards so a controversial
examples been the plastic straws
Wilder.
Made of a material that is
technically recyclable because
their small size and weight.
They tend to slip through all
the recycling machinery so
practically.
They're not recyclable they're
no longer allowed you will no
longer find plastics rose is
Santa Cruz County businesses.
Same is true of plastic stir
state pencils --
You may not be aware that --
If you buy a Cup of coffee to go.
That paper Cup is lined with
plastic but not in Santa Cruz
County.
In there many other similar
changes that we've implemented.
Beginning almost two years ago
now and it's been extremely
effective.
The excellent.
I mentioned where we tend to
innovate --
It's it's both a blessing and
sometimes it occurs that there's
so much.
Support here for environmental
protection that --
People --
Tend to give us kudos for about
a week and then they want to
know what else you got.
So we're always looking to do
more.
And often because we go first.
We hear from other cities
counties other states even other
countries how did you do this
can I get a copy.
How can we do that?
In you should is duplicated many
many times --
Ordinances that were first
introduced in Santa Cruz County.
Have been adopted in San
Francisco Seattle.
Boulder Colorado New York City
many other places.
Next slide please.
I want to talk a little bit
about working with big business
sometimes when we talk about
these issues we see them as the
problem as the enemy.
And I want to encourage people
to think about the opportunities
for partnerships.
We have found that the leverage
provided.
By a well crafted initiative
even at the local level even a
small jurisdiction like this.
Can have profound consequences
and we have lots of examples of
those and I just mention a
couple here that I want to share
with you --
When we introduce the bad I Poly
starring from in food service?
All local businesses got on
board very quickly some of the
national chains set up.
Are we gonna do this.
And we talked to the local
managers and it's a you know we
get this stuff from a warehouse
at a Denver or Chicago or Dallas.
Is sorted at the corporate level
we have nothing to say about
what we use.
You're going to have to talk to
the corporate office so we
didn't that.
And sometimes it was easy
sometimes it was a struggle cold
stone creamery was a struggle
you may be familiar with them
there at nationwide ice cream
chain and at that time.
They were serving all of their
ice cream.
And polystyrene foam balls and
they like them they worked well
they're cheap they were easy.
But we told him we gotta get rid
of them.
And I I'll simplify a lot of
backing for discussion.
They finally called and said
okay we're going to do it's a
great.
So you change out the supplies
in your local store.
The sudden --
That's too much trouble we're
gonna change of all fourteen
hundred stores nationwide.
Because of a local ordinance.
Senate he mentioned Starbucks we
went through a similar process
with them.
More recently some of you may
remember several years ago.
Starbucks trumpeted as a nation
initiative to recycle all of
their products.
And it was an abysmal failure
stuff was actually going to the
landfill.
They were really embarrassed
they failed burned.
They were reluctant to go
through that again.
And yet they are serious about
becoming more sustainable as
many companies are some of them
really just.
Trying to do this as a marketing
measure but many of them are
serious and they just need a
little help to figure out how.
Knowing that about Starbucks we
talk to their corporate office
in Seattle and said look.
We're introducing these new
rules locally it's only gonna
affect four stores in Santa Cruz
County.
Why don't you see this as an
experiment?
It'll work so well here.
Maybe you can introduce some of
this more broadly.
Well it worked out very well and
some of you probably saw their
press release.
A few months ago that based on
their success in Santa Cruz
County the rolling out these
changes to more than twenty
eight thousand stores around the
world.
As referred there still some
glitches they still have some
more work to do but they're
making progress and we're happy
to help them.
Next slide please.
Catherine mentioned some of the
things in the pipeline and I'll
tell you just a bit more about
them -- One
of our problems and she
mentioned.
Is those millions of little
plastic bottles of personal care
products in hotels and motels
Mostra which get.
Thrown away at the end of every
day because it's not practical
for housekeeping to determine
whether they've been used or not
is incredibly wasteful.
On November twentieth we're
going to be introducing an
ordinance to require hotels and
motels in Santa Cruz County. To
switch to refill.
Six we are confident that once
this is implemented people
everywhere else are going to say
again.
Why we think of that let's do
that [inaudible]
I am.
We heard a little bit about
plastic micro fibers.
This may be in new issue to some
of you.
Most of our close these days are
made of synthetic fibers and
every time you do a load of
laundry.
As many as hundreds of thousands
of micro fibers are shot by
those close the passed right
through waste water treatment
plants out to the rivers lakes
and oceans.
What is Catherine mentioned
there's a P. simple solution?
They're already filters on the
market they're easy to install
their widely available they're
very affordable.
So we're going to be introducing
an ordinance and to require the
installation of these filters on
washing machines we're going to
begin with commercial
establishments.
And hopefully phase in all
washing machines over the course
of the next three years.
And again it's something that we
expect to see become widespread.
And if you want to be as to the
punch and do it at the state
level I'd be happy to work with
you.
Next slide please.
So there's more to come but I'm
gonna start there but before I
finish I want to offer a special
thank you.
The innovations that we've we've
created in this county would not
be possible without.
Courageous political leadership.
Some of you know the before you
joined the assembly.
Mark stone was a Santa Cruz
County super in a lot of the
measures that I've discussed
happen under his leadership.
Sir thank you for that mark.
Alright thank you.
Charles welcome.
Thank you good morning.
Assembly member stone.
Cartier Friedman and Kalra on
Chuck help get --
Director of government affairs
for public services.
On all dispensed with the usual
company credits by simply saying
that Republic services is a
national solid waste services
company.
Appalling operations recycling
operations composting operations
in landfills across California.
And plastics are a major part of
what we what we do --
I'm very pleased to be invited
here today --
As I guess the token waste
management presenter --
Is specifically on that account
I'll discuss the impacts that
China swords --
Has on a recycling operations
touch on recyclability.
Excuse me plastics and briefly
discuss policy options next
slide please.
Even before China --
Shut the door on recyclable
commodities we're seeing a
significant decline in class
prices.
Of 40% decline in.
And cardboard.
Late last year.
China basically slammed the door
on on mixed paper and many
plastics do their restrictions
on on cross contamination --
How does this relate to plastics
are mature cover facilities are
constructed to handle single
products? For the most part --
Even was sources we have comical
recycle so we must process and
separate.
And and turn into a recyclable
commodity --
Cross contamination of
recyclables or off spec plastics
are largely responsible for
contamination.
In our paper loads --
Reducing the value and reducing
recyclability of those materials.
Slide three please.
Shows you some of the trends
that have occurred and materials
management from our perspective --
This material trends of also
increased contamination and the
increase recycling costs
[inaudible]
And they've also increased
consumer misunderstanding I
think it was truly recyclable --
Is example newsprint has
virtually disappeared it was a
large part of our are wonderful
recycling numbers that we've had
in the past retributive to news
print -- But
newsprint is disappearing we're
we're now reading are.
Our news on our telephones and
and we're not ordering or
getting newspapers delivered --
HSDPA which is recycling which
is a recycle commodity --
Is being replaced by lighter
weight off spec PT.
Hard to distinguish between the
two and when you.
Run those through a every
facility it is virtually
impossible.
On ten cans of a replacement on
recycled local PA a copolymer --
Pouches.
And water bottles are
increasingly being light
weighted requiring more
containers baton of recyclable
materials recycle plastics.
And again increasing shipping
costs and processing because for
us.
Next slide please.
China swords reduce
contamination --
Late last year 25% in band all
mixed paper.
I'm driving costs across the
board and recycling facilities --
Requiring increased --
Processing time slowing or or
material recovery facilities
lines down adding additional
people to the pick lines --
And all these.
Dramatically increased our costs.
And while markets in Vietnam
went in and with the market
disappearing in China but will
markets growing in Vietnam in
India to some degrees help the
prices --
Prices continue to be very very
deflated for most commodities.
Slide.
Five I'm just a this is a brief
summary of our really simplistic
cost structure --
Our costs.
Of our recycling programs that
we pass on to rate payers are
based on collection costs.
Plus processing costs.
Plus disposal of residuals.
Minus commodity prices.
When cost increases sales price
decrease went up and operating
loss preventing investment to
newer?
And better recycling
infrastructure.
Next slide please.
This chart is from cal recycle
and reflects the again the
dramatic decline.
In the China market for
recyclable materials.
And and we all know what we've
heard the impact of China sorts
on mixed papers and all but I I
think what's striking here is
well there weren't a lot of
plastics going there.
Those mark mark to virtually --
Been shut off completely.
Next slide please.
So.
Can we recycle our way out of
out of plastic pollution --
I would submit that the answer
to that question is no.
Not at least with our current
economic model in our current --
Solid waste recycling
infrastructure --
That model has been broken by by
China's swords a minute
somewhere is.
Broken in a way that has made us
rethink what we do and how we
handle recycling --
Across the board not just in
California but across the
country --
We've.
Become accustomed to shipping
materials to to China with
excessive amounts of
contamination.
And that is no longer a
possibility.
Sorry moving in non recyclable
plastic contamination food
contamination off specs plastic
and any plastics three through --
Seven increases Acosta
processing --
And the value of our commodities
are be reduced at and at the
same time the value of our
materials are are are
commodities are be reduced by at
least half.
So again this is a model that
can survive from an economic
perspective.
And that means more of these
recycled plastics wind up our
landfills and increasingly high
costs.
And potentially more on our
lands and in our waterways
sisters costs increase and an
illegal dumping --
Increases as well.
A just single example of of a
and I like to use the highlight
this -- Very
the flexible plastics are very
large problem for us --
They're very light --
This certainly serve a useful
purpose and I want to talk about
flexible plastic sandwich bags
would be an example --
Stretch plastic --
Around your the shrink wrap it
goes around packaging --
They they serve useful
commercial purposes there's no
no doubt about that but these
materials.
All there are less than 4% of
our commodities stroke or our
waste stream.
Are about 70% of our problems.
And those problems again or
cross contamination the fact
that they're indistinguishable
in optical sorters inner discs
orders from paper --
Their let eight create literate
our facilities --
And a increasingly create
equipment failures are
facilities particularly the
shrink wrap materials which tend
to get wrapped in toward discs
orders and shut down our
operations.
Next slide please --
Our existing and and we saw
earlier slide that somewhat
resembles this but right now our
our our existing plastic
recycling system council.
And in a significant way on a
bottle bill one might many of
our revenues a commensurate your
recovery facilities are result
of the bottle bill --
With merriment the minimum
recycle content requirements and
there are some some bands and
most recently a state level the
the single use plastic bag ban.
Next slide please.
So so policy considerations --
That that at least I would
throughout forward for
discussion today --
And whatever we do I I really do
think we need to consider the
true cost of recycling.
In and focus our efforts on that
which is is truly recyclable --
Consider minimum content were
recycling opportunities --
Infrastructure and markets
support that form for coverage --
Or that fails focus efforts on
extended producer responsibility
any PR.
Reuse and and potentially
mandatory take back programs.
Of for the very very hard to
manage materials --
User fees for disincentive
certainly have something that we
have talked about --
They can be a disincentive for
they can also be used as
incentives to support more
effective and broader recycling
programs --
And I think we we we can't state
enough and I think you've seen
it on many of the slides here
from from this panel
particularly.
Consumer education is is is
critical contamination issue
starts -- In
it and it is from our
perspective it starts from from
the generator of the waste --
We can we can certainly talk
about how we must change the the
plastics waste stream but again
consumer consumer education on
what they by.
And how they treat their
recyclables what they throw in
the recycling bins is is really
critical to our success
recycling.
Thank you [inaudible]
Thank you.
What what's interesting was a
lot of the impetus here's Santa
Cruz County for making some of
these changes?
Was fifteen years ago
realization the landfill was
going to close.
Add.
Try to find another site.
In a small county which proved
absolutely impossible.
That force people to think
differently about waste and
waste management and ensuring
that we had resources in the
county instead of sending things
out.
Took responsibility.
For what we were using how we
were using at and that made it a
lot easier to generate the
political will for the plastic
bag ban the polystyrene a number
of those initiatives because I
think the population.
Woken up to taking
responsibility.
It's interesting China's kind of
the same thing to us by closing
those markets.
It should be shameful that our
solutions are shipping things
off to other countries.
Adding to their burdens just
because of our convenient.
And so the the current state I'm
hoping in this is why it's very
good having.
This.
Waste side focus on this panel
we had lots of discussions
around.
Plus the pollution plastic
products plastic is here to stay
I don't think we're getting rid
of it.
But how we reduce it how we be
responsible across the spectrum
from manufacturing manufactured
choices distribution choices
which will have to do with the
packaging and and distribution
and then end of life.
And finding a better way for
everyone to take responsibility
that's that was.
Actually the impetus for getting
things done here waking up
because nobody wanted a landfill
their backyard.
And we're going to be shipping
about a state bearing of stuff
in the desert who knows what
which is the all has
catastrophic consequences.
And so it's great to see some of
those solutions politically some
of those obviously are going to
be easier.
Than others but getting
Californians to understand the
impact of the decisions that
they may.
Have that we can't we we no
longer have options just to take
that stuff shipped away out of
sight out of mind the take
responsibility for what we what
we use here.
I think will be helpful.
But difficult as we move through
the process so that they get a I
think you for offering solutions
and looking at what's possible.
And in and the difficult
conversations of folks have and
a member with the plastic bag
band.
Save our shores was helpful in
putting data medially soon as
that was proposed so I reduction
in plastic bags in the
environment long before the
origins took a fact so again.
That public education the
discourse has a has its desired
effect and in changing people's
behavior.
So other questions this Friedman
I have a question I have a
question about --
How Santa Cruz does enforcement
with their local ordinances and
I was thinking again about?
Being last night at a restaurant
which is literally on the pier.
And being given without request
plastic straws so it's one thing
to have --
Businesses that are compliant
because they want to be but what
do you do about the out liars
like that and do you have.
You have some sort of
enforcement mechanism and how
does that work.
We do.
Of begin by saying in this
particular case although I work
for the county and the work is
in the city.
I'm going to be contacting my
colleagues at the city when I
leave here and left another
something here for you to follow
up on on and I do that all the
time we do it for each other
they called me as well.
All of our ordinances included
in for spent provisions
penalties for violations.
Our emphasis is more on
education in compliance when we
find problems we often learn
that it's a new employee it's a
misunderstanding so.
Our first step is to try to help
people comply --
But but there are sticks in the
ordinances we can levy
substantial penalties and on the
rare occasions where we found
reluctance the the knowledge of
that has been a powerful
incentive.
We also have another very school
available to us here.
And that's are very
environmentally conscious
residents --
I guarantee you that a lot of
local people if they stop in
that same residents restaurant.
Going to say what the heck are
you doing.
This is plastic this is not
allowed you have to deal with
this right now.
And a lot of businesses that
would be much more responsive to
an average customer then they're
going to be to a call for me.
So we use all of those things
and we really see very high
levels of compliance
[inaudible]
This car.
Thank you and and thanks the
presentation --
And I think --
One of the well one of the
common themes is.
That.
Local governance local regional
actions are or in some ways kind
of the the pilot programs or the
the the experimental place where
you can experiment whether it's
just topics working with local
governments trying something out
doesn't work.
Try something different --
And kind of having that
opportunity for the laboratory
but I think.
A lot of the companies that are
more forward thinking understand
consumer preference --
And what's coming down the road
and so if they see what's
happening in Santa Cruz and
Berkeley.
That it's gonna mention
happening in Francisco LA.
San Jose and its attention
compass in the California and so
for a smart company will pay
attention as a with a second
this is where.
A ventrally consumer choice is
going to get as we get more
educated as people have more
options and choices they're
gonna start making the choices
that are good for themselves
health wise.
Good for the planet --
And what have you and so --
Even when we're doing our
plastic bag and literally being
internet goes this was before it
was a fact giving reusable bags
to people and explaining what
was coming down the road in the
red reality is that people.
The card that you get some
postal complain about a little
bit about the initially that
behavior changes.
And then allows the state --
To use the path that you now
have a couple together a bunch
of local jurisdictions the now
create the momentum to do it at
a state level.
And so I really appreciate.
What you're doing?
Here in this region as a really
important laboratory for the
nation.
In terms of pushing forward
things that yeah you know what
tomorrow if we introduce in
Sacramento will go through maybe
not.
But intentionally because the
work you're doing allows us as
legislators that.
That certainly.
You know want to move in the
direction you're going.
The ability to be able to point
to data point to facts point to
consumer choice --
In a very meaningful way some
very grateful for that and so
thank you for that as well as
the industry respect that look
you know and I think floor as
question the prior.
Panel about spot with those are
all things that we have to be
cognizant of because if we get
these major retailers is major --
Companies to come on board
that's huge and that creates
momentum for others jump on
board because obviously the the
public publicity.
And PR and people wanting to do
the right thing well you know if
a company like Starbucks gonna
do then I feel better about
Starbucks and going there as a
consumer well guess what the
other companies are charging.
Too and so knowing the data on
what the cost is to both of the
the companies they're supplying
the products.
As well as to recyclers and the
challenges they have because
it's easy to say always recycle
everything about solve the
problem and and hearing the
challenges with that helps us
then it would be create policies
a wall.
Of the policies are created were
really good twenty years ago
they don't actually work today
for the recyclers and other
things that we can do better so
I'm I I think this
conversation's really helpful.
For me Texas that that think
about and how we move forward as
a state but again encouraging
that local --
Energy and the the the local
activism is as important. For
that question about the plastic
and glass.
They have been studies done.
In in in these studies are
mostly called life cycle
assessments and life cycle cost
assessments.
In you know often plastic is
going to turn out from the life
cycle assessment to be the
material of choice it's light
weight it's an expensive.
Theoretically it's recyclable
you put all of those things into
his study with boundaries that
are set by.
The researcher or that or the
study conductor.
In you can pretty much get the
answer that you want.
But in terms of plastic verse
plastic is much later.
Much less expensive.
And so there's been this mass
migration away from plot glass
bottles to plastic bottles
because it also reduces
greenhouse gas when you're
transporting.
You know billions of glass
bottles around the country and
around the globe we're talking
about you know heavy containers
a lot more --
Energy for transport at center
and the green greenhouse gases
go up.
Would actually require me using
a glass bottle forty times. To
equal the same greenhouse gas
level in reductions is using one
plastic bottles you have to
recycle that glass forty we use
that not recycling actually we
use it.
And I think the challenge there
is that we've gone in this
global economy.
When I was a kid I used to take
my coke bottles yes I drink coke
as a kid?
I used to take him back to the
corner store put him in a little.
You know look like a a crate you
know with what's in it for each
bottle.
And they would take them to see
that local bottling facility
maybe thirty forty miles away
washed and sterilised them in
you know come back out on the
market and they all looked can't.
Cool all scratched up and cloudy
and sort of fun you know.
And no they can't do that
they're about three glass
manufacturers in the country.
If you were gonna collect glass
bottles and send them from
Florida to Colorado where there
is a glass re processor.
Were talking a lot of money but
we are seeing some some of the
local breweries begin to do that
especially in Colorado where
they do have a glass facility.
So they are often the furries
themselves are taking them back
re watching them in.
Sterilizing them and putting
them back out on the market but
but the real you know who the
real.
Issue is greenhouse gasses
associated with the heavier
materials.
Mr. card sure this.
Couple observations first.
So you use the examples of John
which you said [inaudible]
Tom. Ten year old twin girls let
job which is --
And so you know the used to be
of course this fire phone.
Containers.
But and now they transitioned at
as you said but last night.
So you go from really bad day
kind of bad so they don't break
down in that stuck in the sand.
But there entities that.
Cannot be recycled so.
I guess that's a win but it's
not.
A perfect --
So just kind of you have to
remind yourself that by making
this transition from cold stone
the same scenario there from the
ice cream phone to that.
Cardboard line thing that's not
recyclable --
And and the issue that we're
gonna face if.
Any four of us I'm sure we
support many measures have not
offer them ourselves.
Is -- When
we try to get these things pass
of the state level as?
Like food containers with other
compostable recyclable.
If the cost passed on to
consumers is going.
To in our RD raising their gas
taxes and you know and minimum
wage increases and you hear from
the opposition all these
arguments left and right.
So how do we respond to that are
are there any examples for you.
Is how much has that.
Item of whatever product --
Gonna.
Cost or has stayed the same.
When we me EMTs efforts?
That was a concern --
The availability --
Truly recyclable and compostable
food service products was
limited the quality was somewhat
uneven --
Sometimes the performance left
something to be desired I
personally experience putting a
compostable spoon and nobles
super watching and Mel.
We've come a long way.
I mentioned the rules we
implemented last year requiring
all of those food service
materials to be recyclable and
compostable.
Before we ever talk to the food
service businesses we talk to
the distributors that the
wholesalers we let him know that
this is common.
Is this going to be a problem
for you we one of them.
Not a bit.
This industry has just
mushroomed.
There's so many products
available there are many to
choose from.
There available for every
conceivable use they perform
gray.
And they're very affordable so
that was an issue years ago but
but I can confidently say it
really isn't any longer.
So on the app for example
styrofoam.
X. poly styrene only.
Like sorry.
He there are the restaurants
whether it's you know.
Panda express what have you the
national chains date counter and
say now that increases --
The cost to consumers.
So.
When they come out?
I am and I and I can show you
examples that are just as
affordable we've we've done the
homework and I can tell you that
our order supervisors always ask
that question.
What's going to be the impact on
local businesses how is this
going to affect their class and
I've learned to do my homework.
So when I bring a measure
forward like this I'm ready with
a list of twenty products for or
more.
Learning.
As well that are readily
available and don't cost anymore.
So we we hear a lot --
Predictions.
There's often --
No accurate information behind
so they really don't cost me
more money and they are.
Able to be utilized.
With the consumer in the same.
Manner not having you know I've
I've.
I've bought a little --
Pressed use the straws in it
falls apart after like virus so
please see you gotta make sure
you.
So I know they're they're
probably iron in summer better
than other fixing those things
out.
So.
If they really are no cost
difference why would they not
just to the natural it doesn't
help these restaurants to be
using -- The
single use things that.
A third maybe of their customers
look at so you know what I just
don't like this someone.
Like Starbucks are beginning to
realize that.
This is not just a way to look
greener.
Make people happier but it makes
business sense.
Inertia is N. issue people are
afraid of change they're used to
doing things the way that
they've been doing them they've.
Had these long established
supply change they don't see any
reason to do it any differently.
And it's while we institute
these men those problems and
offer them solutions up front
because we wanted to be easy for
everybody. For example if I can.
On the six initiatives that we
are taking on currently.
I am working with for students
from Middlebury Middlebury
institute friends International
Studies and there graduate.
Sustainability program in there
doing exactly this kind of
research how many companies so
many individual businesses in
the county or in the city
jurisdiction will be affected.
By this ordinance will it be a
cost to them only be a cost
savings are there alternatives
how easy and they to come.
About the work we're doing that
research and bringing it forward --
You know one of the reasons
we're likely to see.
The ban on toiletry bottles that
we've asked for is because that
is a cost savings to businesses
and they've already discovered
some of this on their own and
are moving in that direction so.
That's almost a no brainer for
work for you folks and in the
legislature to to look at and
saying we can actually help
these.
This industry get to cost
savings faster --
You know they're the higher end
hotels there have been surveys
done where.
They say their customers will
feel if they the luxury of their
own personal product that hasn't
been touched by anybody else but
you know that's pretty much just
the really.
Once used Cervantes [inaudible]
Pretty high.
And customer in.
Most of them.
I don't think or even really
paying attention to it we're
seeing these kinds of changes
across most of the hotel chain
so there.
It.
On the actual plan think about
80% plus of the hotel motel
owners are south Asian some very
but it is. To turn of
deregulation into changing their
business models so --
It may take a little bit of time
but again Santa Cruz going first
and working with local hotels
motels you a lot of to a big
tourism industry here.
Helps so much to that have large
conversation with their advocacy
organization.
And to talk a look they're doing
it there how can we do this in a
way that's most would you have
any sense of the it not all
business of the same so when we
did.
A poly styrene for take out in
San Jose we did.
Plastic bags we had a different
time frame for the larger. One
companies that I've economies of
scale of the the franchises and
the chains had up.
Had up complies sooner the small
mom and pop so they have not
save a bridge yeah and so that
we have any sense of that with
recognize a love these there
that.
Some of the arguments of
business they're not just all by
you know just all made up just
to resist change there are
especially the smaller
businesses are some.
Tensions there apps and so
whatever we can do to kind of
smooth it out but make sure we
don't take steps backward orders
or stand still that we have to
keep moving.
Forward and so again I think
what you're doing is really
helpful.
Edits learning experience to for
the businesses when we did the
original poly styrene bad for
take out.
There was a great deal of
concern about existing product
so we actually built in and
implementation that was longer
but we ask them to come back and
apply [inaudible]
Nobody did.
So they were able actually to
shift to the new product much
more quickly than they thought
they were and so part of the
implementation is giving a
little bit of leeway
[inaudible]
But working with with some
parameters that that can work
and I think the businesses and
so at for future steps that were
taken those issues didn't arise
because of the experience.
That the businesses here had and
they understood that they could
in fact implement.
And then I would add the in in
this particular case our very
first step was to meet with the
local hotel and motel owners
managers.
And that's what do you think
about this how would this affect
you what kind of problems might
not be aware of what do you know
that we don't know.
And we always take that approach
with on a blind side people we
want to find workable solutions.
At the same time you know like I
said I've spent many years in my
career actually working in
corporate sustainability and
have consulted to a lot of
companies you produced.
Some of the projects that.
Now on this side of the fence
I'm.
Looking to help eliminate.
But you know at some point where
we do have to look at the
economics you know we are our
world is driven by an economy.
And arguably it's not the right
economic model right now but
when we need to look at that we
also need to keep.
Firmly planted I think even have
a claim it crisis and we have a
plastic policing crisis.
That it won't matter if there
are businesses or if we have
conveniences if our ocean dice
we die.
That is our most important
resource and if we aren't
willing to step up and make the
hard decisions and forests
businesses from time to time to
make a hard choice [inaudible]
While hopefully not until after
I'm dead which is often a
consolation having use since
I've been working in this field
for over thirty years that I'll
be gone before it's really bad
but it's going to get really bad
if we don't make some pretty
hard choices pretty fast.
Right.
I know we were just public
comment yeah we want you to
overcome it and we were quick
thing up I want to just notice.
Make the notion here that.
If we're pushing for more
compostable recycling single use
products we run into the issue
the recycling history and we're
gonna have a not I'm vibrant --
Joining these to select
committees because they're
they're intertwined.
Really big hearing --
Nearly twenty eighteen talking
about this issues [inaudible]
Select --
But that one of the issues is --
Is this the reality of what's
happening with China in the
global market so we could push.
All these products to recycling.
But then if we don't have a way.
To have a viable recycling --
System in California that what
is what is that mean.
We have stacks of contaminated.
Alex of contaminated material
that we can't sell any place
piling up --
Merger recovery facilities and
and getting weathered in getting
pushed to the point at some
point in time where it's
weathered it can't be recycled
at all.
That's what we've we've really
seen when China soared initially
had that's leveled out some the
crisis is.
Still here but it's it's it's
smaller but that.
Many like I couldn't see any
better than you than you did it.
We have to be careful what we
ask for sometimes and and what
would push into the recycling
stream.
I I guess the best advice I
could give this let's be really
good at this it and recycling
the stuff that is recycle.
And make those determinations
then try to figure out other
alternatives to push of the
material.
Street and good point okay so
thank you for your patience.
Select committee process is a
way of getting information
that's what we have the panels
into the legislative contacts.
So now is your opportunity is
members of the public to breast
to address us briefly your
comments.
And we take all of this and for
we'll.
On the slick committee websites
will try to post --
Power points in as much
information as we can so it
becomes publicly available.
As education for us as well as
for our colleague so if anyone
would like to addresses.
This is your opportunity Nicole
has the microphone.
Good morning this is doctor cold
executive director of Cochran
product stewardship council --
I want to touch on the Starbucks
items I thought that was pretty
in.
That a year and a half ago we
had discussions with a company
that was creating a silica based
wind.
Paper Cup they approached
Starbucks as an alternative to
the classic wine.
And the biggest problem
Starbucks love the bill of the
idea that the biggest problem
was.
They couldn't.
Get enough of a made.
It was a demand problem is.
Scalability and so and I and I
suspect now they finally figured
it out in this weather able
rolled out nationwide vertical
while. To get that rolled out so
I'm glad to see if get witness
plus going cut --
So --
Governor posters of counsel's in
the PR expert we're here to help --
Assembly members are always open
to come to see you help yell or
if you need --
With any of these products as we
look at it as absolutely have
manufactures dealing with these
products that end of life health
and agree. To by a greener
design and will have a better
product overall at the end
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Others raise your hands.
Hi -- So
this conversation has been
focused on the individual
consumer.
Of as far as what we should do.
What about --
Is a large usage of plastics a
with AG every time I go past the
fields and see that they're
covered with plastic that our
food is growing.
In plastic.
Of the medical waste industry is
enormous.
Of and electronics ayes
something it is filled with
plastic and we're not going to
not use electronics.
We're not gonna not buy.
Foods that are grown in all this
plastic but what's being done in
our their figures comparing
where --
That volume of waste such as AG
medical industry and electronics
with -- What
consumers use safer takeout and
plastic bags and?
Bottles.
Thanks action reaction is what
what are you doing.
About those more.
What if your to me to be harder
I don't know if they are larger
not?
Thank you yeah --
Good afternoon --
My name is Jeff Chester I'm
representing Oceania Oceania is
the largest conservation group --
Internationally that is what
will focus specifically and
exclusively on oceans ands and
we're we're actually working on
launching a global plastics --
Campaign --
And and actually Blake --
And I are here at the local
level region both in --
Monterey as were based --
I also in the Monterey Bay
charter school ocean garden --
Guardian coordinator --
Through the no --
National marine sanctuaries
program where the school in in
Monterey has actually made a
three year commitment to go
towards zero waste as a school --
And the kids are are extremely
excited about it the kids get it
right away and it's the parents
we got to worry about --
Six are obviously a a huge
problem for all the reasons
people talk about I think we'd
like to see kind of a an effort
to move away from just the idea
of disposable idea products in
general --
Ends in --
Ultimately the the issue of of
production and it had hit
tackling not is is certainly the
big -- One
where we are we're in the U. K.
or and the and the your and in
Europe that they're now tackling
it this problem in a
comprehensive way rather than
just looking at kind of one
product at a time.
They're doing a comprehensive --
Of solution or package that
includes both in the phase outs
of specific worst offender
single use products as well as
mandatory reductions and others
as well as financial incentives
to bring on more durables and
reusable materials.
And so you'll California has a
history of doing comprehensive
legislation like --
Assembly bill thirty two to
address climate in legacy of
California --
But so far the plastics work
well we have made some aye thing
major progress and emerge as a
leader in some areas it has been
too piecemeal and it is
insufficient given the growth of
the problem.
And so we are are hoping to work --
And come together with various
NGOs -- Very
various businesses and hoping to
see more of a coordinated effort
in the California legislature to
try to take a comprehensive
approach to to these issues --
And and really didn't use the
momentum that's building now to
get more serious about this
problem so thank you for keeping
an eye on your agenda and we are
we're here to help in this fight
thank you very much.
Hi good afternoon my class of
environmental organization
Californians against waste. For
someone committee for having
this hearing you've done a
amazing job of keeping the
drumbeat going both in the
legislative action you've taken.
This past year in the last few
years and then having hearings
and briefings and other things
in Sacramento.
I I think to to my to the point
of my colleague from Oceania.
We need to start looking at this
comprehensively.
We have a very big problem that
seems intractable.
And the way we handle these
intractable problems is through
comprehensive policies.
And I it's more or less told the
comments right I my mouth.
But I think we as a society as a
state need to start saying.
We can't have an infinite growth
and disposal plastics.
We need to cap them out of
classic we generate and reduce
that over time.
And you know it's it's the
timing of this hearing.
Is really appropriate --
Given that.
Kind three major news stories in
the past week --
One of the stories was about a
week ago when they announced
that they test the table salt.
In 90% of the table salt they
tested had micro plastic.
A couple days ago there was ever
a researcher that an ounce a the
taste tested --
Stool samples and found 1100% of
the stool samples.
How plastic?
Which might actually kind of be
good news because at least a
fleeting the system.
And then the news today coming
out of Europe is that they just
adopted a comprehensive
framework. To phase out the use
of of single use products that
have alternatives.
And setting up a framework to
reduce the ones that don't.
And so I think there's a lot
more work to do but it's it's a
lot easier to do nothing and I
commend you having this
conversation and for keeping a
dialogue going.
Thank you.
Good afternoon thank you so much
for having this conference today
my name is Rachel cap and I'm
environmental projects
coordinator for the city of
what's involved.
I've to comments about the trash
provision first as my
understanding of the trash
provision how we are to quantify
the water quality benefits of
reducing trash that end up in a
receiving waters.
So it seems to me that something
that we should really be
focusing on are the types of
persistent plastics that have
chemicals that here to them.
Or leach chemicals into our
water such as cigarette* or
agricultural plastics that carry
the methyl bromide or other
kinds of pollutants I'm out
encourage that that be something
that we look at as we go through
our trash man that.
Secondly I am now working on
coordinating that at best
management practices for our
trash provision it kind of feels
like throwing spaghetti at a
wall and hoping that.
Other departments and divisions
within the city feel committed
to our storm water program --
Primarily that has been a public
works AB really heavy hitting
area of so I would also
encourage the state to think
about ways to include our police
or are parks and and make sure
that we're looking at it and a
city wide scale including
enforcement.
And code at enforcement is a
huge issue in Watsonville and
last but certainly not least I
wanted to speak to the
inclusivity of this movement.
Specifically to any wall from
reaching out to the disability
community related to straws --
And to think about that with
south county so.
I'm a 100% on board with banning
bottled water but we have people
in our community who have come
from places where you can't
drink the water and so is to
think of our community as being
able to just immediately.
Get rid of it you know we're not
the community that's
significantly a challenge for us
so for us to really invite our
whole community when we look at
issues like these.
And I really appreciate that
thank you --
High -- My
name's George on and chief
scientist --
Edition its service to live here
in Santa Cruz I want to pick up
on what Jeff said --
Thank you mark for hosting this --
This panel this is critical.
And energy Conservancy we worked
worked on this issue for a
number of years and a lot of
beach cleanups but we've
increasingly been focused on the
question of waste management.
And farther up the chain where
the materials are coming from
and it is absolutely critical to
have the recycling industry in
the room but the one group of
folks that are not in this
conversation right now are the
producers of the materials the
world talking about.
At the end of the day the
fundamental problem with
plastics is it's not worth very
much you see that coming through
the recycling community it's the
reason that it's easier to use
plastic and glass or other
things.
And so we fundamentally have to
get this question of the cost
and the value of plastics and
ultimately I think that brings
us back to corporate
responsibility an extended
producer responsibility.
And I think you'll be really
great if we could figure out a
re way to reset that
conversation my understanding
and I'm no expert.
Is that has become very toxic in
this country the responsibility
in the context of plastics and
ocean health would be really
nice way to kind of reset the
conversation.
And figure out and really
practical ways what is our
shared responsibility and what
is the private sector's
responsibility here in solving
this problem so I'd encourage
you to go for to think about
that way [inaudible]
Thank you.
Right no one else.
Hey signal closing thoughts
members.
Well just getting back to the
idea of cost and value you know
earlier --
We heard the discussion about
the cost municipalities of
having to clean up.
Through filtration --
The material that's going
through their community through
storm drains and streams.
And yet that cost which is being
paid for by taxpayers and
ratepayers is not calculated
when we talk about the cost to
let's say business.
And so re framing --
How we think of these I think is
really important something that
USCIS policy makers can maybe
help?
Figure out a way to do in right
now Los Angeles is in the
process of voting on measure W.
which is a parcel tax for storm
water clean out.
And a lot of people say but I
didn't because shin so --
There's a real inequity to how
the costs --
It really are being borne by
society you know particularly
cities that --
A our coastal cities and have to
pay a bigger burden of costs
because they're the ones that
are interacting with the ocean
in a different way.
So -- Trying
to help --
Re adjust that and show those
true cost like you were talking
about because the amount of
carbon coming out of trucks
transporting glass but there's
new data emerging about the
amount of greenhouse gases that
leak leak.
Out of plastic bottles and
that's never been calculated
before so making sure that we
have a really holistic --
View of the costs and that the
costs are being --
Equitably dispersed --
And I think that the the
manufacturing industry.
They understand that where
they're way ahead of us and
that's why you see.
Reactions to things like
tethering bottle caps which
would seem like such a no
brainer to so many of us become
huge bottles in Sacramento or a
plastic bag ban or whatever else
it is.
So I I do think that it is --
Really -- An
imperative of the legislature to
try to get a better
understanding of all of that.
And it's great to see so many
people being activated --
And I will say it's a lot easier
for people in the coast who.
Through education understand the
issues but also see it in their
backyards it's very different
story if you're talking about
going into other areas of the
state that don't interact as
much with the coastline.
That I have their own economic
that costs for them is a much
higher percentage of their
everyday lives so it hurts more.
For them to deal with an issue
that they see is very far away
and remote.
I don't understand so I I just
put that out of some of the
challenges that we all have to
try to deal with when we put
these policies forward and be
very aware of I'm at the same
time.
As you so eloquently said we
can't let that stop us because
the survival of you know our
planet is really at stake in
that sounds very dramatic.
But it's also true so --
I I do think that it's important
to have these conversations and
to try to kind of spread the
message and I'm so glad to see
National Geographic I just.
Doing that I just wish more
people actually read it --
But getting that message out
there is something that
California that when we bring
these policies forward even if
they fail we've started that
conversation.
You know having the conversation
about straws made a lot of
people start thing about
structure ruling.
And about plastic differently I
bet you anything that the market
for metal straws was instantly
created you know which has its
own.
Of positive economic aside again
shirt chair stone and McCarty
for having this for allowing us
to participate I've learned a
lot today I want to thank all
the panelists on that was so
fast that I kept taking slides.
And sending them off my poor
legislative director --
But will be you know streaming
this on all of our social media
sites in trying to spread the
word and I I really want to
thank just the members of the
public in the activists who do
this you know out of passion and
love --
Every single day because your
work is I think starting to to
turn the tide so thanks again.
Thank you notice.
There are yeah is one of the one
at the moment thank you as chair
stone Chen McCarty is as well as
a colleague summer.
Or Friedman --
And I really also want to thank
the panelists I got a lot
information today --
Of it's it's great to be able to
do this we're not in session.
Of only really have the time to
let it -- To
absorb the information think
about it --
In and so it's a totally helpful
and I think that --
You know when it comes.
To quirk responsibility when it
comes to what we can do is read
as a legislature when it comes
to consumer choice.
I think that what we were that
these kinds of conversations
help to build a momentum.
As alluded to but assembly
Friedman with the apple plus
extras in just having people
talk about and then start making
their own choices.
Also adding the young people are
gonna save us once again I think
that you tend to see them.
Carrying around water bottles
much more and be more topple
about this but we need to put in
place.
Of the environment --
To create that behavior change
amongst all of us but especially
our corporate partners that
really needed. To step up and so
I think that --
This is been very helpful for me
and again to the chairs for
organizing this.
Sure yeah thank you again I that
I know that this was an issue
that --
We've been talking about in the
natural resources policy
committee legislation.
Later plastic waste and
recycling I think is important
to have it together is certainly
was in lightning.
I to was --
Excited see the graduate
students here they del.
Went back to class --
Hopefully they'll be part of the
solution --
Bringing some --
Remedies for us to to tackle --
Going forward and I I do think
that there is a social
consciousness going.
Not not just dinner here in
Santa Cruz but across California
but even in areas that don't
necessarily.
See the beautiful coastline
everyday to to know you know.
My little --
Fourth grader a couple years ago
to little project on on on on on
on the impact of a plastic in
the ocean into me to go to the
store and buy.
The six pack thinks for the
plastic thing but on the beard
that fix whatever Kansas so
forth.
And so she had a little turtle
in her room and she put through
their chance little.
An eight year old thinking about
these things and it's just --
It's very very powerful and I
think it's important that we
focus on the next generation
because they're the ones that
will be here.
After us so --
Today give us --
Basically a stark reminder of
what the issues are today in
California across the globe but
also.
Some hope and some remedies from
the local level --
That we can bring about through
the rest of California so --
Look for to work with all you
and future thank you.
Thank you and just to briefly I
think some of the synergies the
comments that are there.
The question really is the
larger question so lot of the
industrial agricultural are
significant piece of it most of
the thin film is is in fact
agricultural and industrial.
We just we had.
Limited time but those are
really also part of what the
broader conversation is
electronic disposal all of that
a lot of local jurisdictions are
taking on I think I would
completely agree I think most of
us agree.
About this notion of extended
produce responsibility.
That's one of the reasons were
holding these is.
To broaden what we know bring
more people into the
conversation right now anything
we do in the legislature that
CPR is a two thirds vote.
At mosa plastic stuff we can't
even get.
Forty one votes in our own house
so our steps are dramatic and we
need to engage more broadly
engage with the industry gauge.
Where we can to look for
solutions that ultimately are
implementable that's one of the
reasons the legislature does
smaller pieces because those?
Are approachable as opposed to
being of the something that is
more comprehensive but
ultimately those with the the
answers we need to get to get to
is a comprehensive conversation
about.
The broader cost societal cost
economic cost of decisions that
have been made and how we can
support the economy but also
protect the environment and
every.
Sector strata academy.
Taking responsibility for its
piece of a solution that
ultimately is is the goal.
But that's what these
conversations lead to hopefully
and I appreciate everybody
coming out on a really beautiful
day here in Santa Cruz tough
duty I know.
But I'll do it thank you all
very much and we are adjourned